all right I guess I'd have to start this
video off by saying WB games sent me
mortal kombat 11 for free I guess I'd
have to say that for disclaimer purposes
otherwise people think I'm an [ __ ] so
there you go there's a disclaimer
legally fulfilled ice not let's talk
about
[Music]
all right so Mortal Kombat 11 is the
11th fighting game in the Mortal Kombat
series picks up after Mortal Kombat
actual leaves Offin there's this new
baddie her name's chronica essentially
elder goddess of time she's here to mess
[ __ ] up and so now you gotta take her
out let's talk about the story mode the
story now it's actually really
compelling though I do feel like they're
using the time thing again essentially
what happened in Mortal Kombat 9 there
wasn't time travel but Raiden sent a
message to himself in the past and so it
changed events going forward in the
first Mortal Kombat trilogy but now
Kronecker comes in messes up some time
line stuff so now present-day Mortal
Kombat characters meet their past selves
doesn't change the fact that some of the
interactions between some of the
characters and their past selves amazing
talking about Johnny Cage every weapon
reviews have talked about Johnny Cage
but is such a relatable thing for
everybody like Johnny Cage is one of the
best arcs in the entirety or more of a
combat started as this douchey cocky
[ __ ] now by Mortal Kombat X he's a
grown family man he's learned a thing or
two he learned that there was more that
he had to offer than just douchey Johnny
Cage so when his past self comes in he's
just like oh my god which I'm not gonna
live 20 something-year-old me met me now
I'd be like it's you learned it's just
such a great theme I do feel like that's
cheap though because with that you can
just undo things that they've done so
there's no real weight to some of the
deaths that have happens there's no
gravity to some of the resolutions some
of the characters have felt by Mortal
Kombat acts Han Solo Sasha it's like
alright I'm kind of over it but no now
you have a past scorpion who Z's the
spectre of vengeance still RL I guess
that's still around to get it out you
want to keep what people love you got to
find new ways of waving it and it's hard
to do what can I say Ronda Rousey plays
Sonya though it's yeah she does well I'm
not gonna her voice acting does lend
itself to Mortal Kombat annihilation
it's not good I'm just saying like I'm
glad that she's living her dream she is
an MMA fighter but it doesn't mean
anything it doesn't matter what a voice
actor looks like or what they can do or
what their particular set of skills is
outside of voice acting if you have
someone who's a great voice actor would
be perfect for Sonya Blade and they lay
gravel on the weekends or they're like a
we buy gold sign spinner who cares it
doesn't matter what they do the fact
that Ronda Rousey can fight doesn't
change the fact that it's not she's not
a voice actor so supposed to be talking
about the fighting element because it's
a fighting game and I do feel like the
gameplay mechanic
this game it does take a deviation it
does go a bit of a different direction
it's not like it's a completely entirely
different game but when I first got into
it I was like this place I got to do the
tutorial even after doing the tutorial I
was like oh yeah different in MKX I felt
like Mortal Kombat X was a leap in the
vein and line of Mortal Kombat 9 MK
Elevens like a leap that goes a bit of a
different direction I feel like it's
more defense oriented like Mortal Kombat
acts really every Mortal Kombat my
philosophy is best defense is a good
offense so I'm a very aggressive fighter
I love scorpion with his two swords I
know everyone online hates people who
use that build but I loved that build
it's just like slash slash hit teleport
hit spirit like I could do it all it was
great this does not play so aggressively
you can tell there's you got to be
methodical the combos are all hit hit
smack come smack smack smack the best
way I could phrase it is Mortal Kombat
11 I feel like is tailored to
competitive fighters like Evo fighters
which means people who just love Mortal
Kombat like my casual ass I'm like oh I
get my balls kick in my five people even
during the tutorial which you got to do
do it by the end of tutorials talking
about frames like this kick has seven
frames this punch has three so be sure
to use that punch when going against
that ky which means there is a learning
curve to us filthy casuals out there you
got to really think about what you do
it's not about going in there it's about
your opponent [ __ ] something up
whipping a move you blocking a move then
you strike it's very block then counter
oriented when you fight online don't
know what I'm talking about really
fighting online is what I call the great
noob saibot fight because everyone plays
with Sun or scorpion
I like Kano in this one Kanto is really
good so that's my take on the combat
it's more complex combat but it's not
how I play Mortal Kombat so I feel like
I'm taking a hit granted people are very
adaptable I could adapt to survive which
I feel like I have because like at first
the towers were crushingly hard and they
were like alright we'll patch them here
here's some coins and hearts and soul
fragments in the meantime I to this I
don't know if they did patch it do they
actually patch it to make the towers
easier if you're like the towers are
easier now I don't know if I just got
better at Mortal Kombat 11 but man for
those first few days holy [ __ ] that was
difficult even now I can't say it's
completely easy because of the gauntlet
I'm in stage 2 of a
power called the gauntlet lock that [ __ ]
I'm just not gonna pass it because
there's life's too good I'm too happy in
life I have a girlfriend who loves me I
love her my dogs are doing well my
family's doing well things are generally
good I just don't need that kind of
stress in my life I don't need that [ __ ]
I don't need to want to throw my
controller through my TV I just don't
need so it looks like the gauntlet stage
- that's where we stopped on that one
gameplay-wise they changed the meter
like before and Mortal Kombat X and 9
you have 3 meter slots that built the
meter bar you did a meter burn special
move it would take one slot away if it
all filled up and you could do your
x-ray move and it really punished
someone now the meters different like
there's a defense meter that's two slots
and offense meter that's two slots and
you get your final blows super special
move at the end when you're hurt enough
and you get one of those per match and
when you meet or burn like that meter
fills back up pretty generously so meter
burning special moves is a huge way it's
a huge mechanic in Mortal Kombat 11 if
you're not meter burning your special
moves
you're not playing Mortal Kombat 11
right you have to meet or burn special
moves just the way it's meant to be
played however I would always rely on
that like people meter burning like all
right you're not gonna hit me with your
X ray move there is at least that I know
that whether it's against the computer
people online I was always safe now the
computer or anyone online can meter burn
the [ __ ] out of there special moves you
punish them enough you hit them enough
now they have their super move they'll
still use that which means if I had a
nickel every time the computer beat me
with that much life left I'd have a lot
of nickels probably enough to buy the
game but admittedly I do like that about
that element of gameplay because I never
really used meter burn special news I
always saved it from my x-ray move chip
damage doesn't do dick let's say that
you know those moments in any previous
Mortal Kombat game where you're like oh
they're almost dead like sweet I'll just
do scorpions teleport move smack them
they'll block but they'll still go down
on me to burn it and hit him twice no it
doesn't do dick they're just gonna do
their super move and kill you I will say
graphically definitely stuff upper
Mortal Kombat acts these graphics are
insane you notice it when you see the
costumes and you know the fabric of each
costume is like oh that's leather that's
cheaper leather that's probably pleather
that's velvet that's cloth that's this
kind of cloth um you can tell that's
really insane and quite brilliant I
guess I'll talk about the cons there's a
lot to talk about with the
streams between costumes costume
controversy a lot of costume [ __ ] there
are seemingly a lot of costumes in this
game but really I'd argue for any given
character there are a couple maybe a few
costumes every other costume is a
variant of those core costumes with
different colors so really you're just
unlocking shaders that's kind of a
bummer I feel like it's a bit of a
bait-and-switch like who's gonna play
sub-zero with a red costume this weird
red sub-zero is called a Mac and he just
has different moves you feel like you're
playing her Mac but with ice powers even
an injustice when you can make sub-zero
different shades when they actually used
a shader system because they were being
honest about it I still kept in blue
green and white scorpion costume but
scorpions yellow and black you can throw
some white in there some red in there
but yellow and black I know maybe I'm a
traditionalist I just think some of the
color schemes for some of the characters
they look weird some of the costumes you
really need scorpions took me a bit of
time to get used to because I liked his
Mortal Kombat X costume so much but I
fell into the appeal of scorpions
costume in this one his baseline costume
anyway the cloth II won but I ended up
liking it kung Laos costumes lame though
it might be more accurate and like
traditional I don't know I'm gonna plead
ignorance on that all I know is that
costume doesn't look as cool as his
previous costumes same with katanas
alright now we'll get into the costume
controversy clearly the female costumes
are not as revealing as they have been
look this is a fighting game fighting
mechanic that's number one for me in a
weird way I see both sides of this
argument here but really the bummer is
retro costumes and throwback costumes to
previous costumes they've had in other
games like katanas costume for Mortal
Kombat 2 maybe Mortal Kombat 3 or
Ultimate Mortal Kombat 3 there's always
fun to unlock those and other Mortal
Kombat games now that's just not a
possibility because they're revealing
costumes and they've said we're not
gonna have sexy revealing costumes in
Mortal Kombat 11 for the women so now
they dress them kind of like ninja nuns
I mean this just comes two short years
after Starfire from injustice two it's
not like she's exactly conservatively
dressed I just want them to be honest
about it don't give me the logic
posturing like well you wouldn't fight
in a bikinis it was more logic no you
wouldn't fight in that [ __ ] thing
either your legs get tangled in that
front part you tribute your [ __ ] ass
kicked they're like two seconds wearing
that thing I do like Jayde's costume
because it's cool like you know the hood
she's an assassin and I think it's neat
but I don't think anyone's gonna go to
some seventh circle of hell if you give
me a throwback Jade costume - just the
katanas cost
is just boring it's just onesie spandex
boring there's no way katanas costume in
mortal kombat 11 is as interesting is
the Mortal Kombat X and nine costumes so
I see why fans who like you guys used to
fight the man and now you're bending the
knee the Mortal Kombat was censored for
Super Nintendo but yeah at a time where
it was like video game violence is gonna
make people killers Ed Boon and the team
that made Mortal Kombat they were like
[ __ ] that and it kind of poked fun at
that whole thing with friendships they
did fight the man and now they're not
and maybe that's the difference between
20-something year old at Boone and
50-something year-old Ed Boon I don't
know just want them to be honest about
it I want someone to be like I we just
don't want to hear about it on social
media for the next few years because we
hear about it about Mortal Kombat 9 all
the time we did that [ __ ] in 2011 and I
get it I'm sure that's obnoxious but in
the end it is a weird call because it is
Mortal Kombat you're still ripping heads
off and ripping spines out don't show
too much skin that would be bad not like
gun violence is a thing but how much leg
did katana show cuz that's the real
question like where do we draw the line
in the sand in a game about killing
people and ripping their heads off
forever their spines out we will ponder
that question as Shao Kahn smashes
someone's head out there [ __ ] so on
one hand I mean social media has grown a
lot in the past few years so that I get
that they're trying to avoid the online
shitstorm that might come from it on the
other hand anyone who would say any [ __ ]
about it probably doesn't play Mortal
Kombat anyway I feel like the gear is a
step back from injustice I can justice
had a few bits of gear that you would
get it would make your characters look
completely different like all of my
Batman's look very different so many
characters that just all look different
in this one you have costumes and you
have three things that you can change
out in any character that's the gear you
get you get gear for three things like
scorpion it's a spear his swords and his
mask his mask you can definitely tell
his spear the combats going so fast
you're not gonna be like oh wait the
spear and the sword is very different
same with Kung Lao one of them is like a
little medallion on his hip off right
you did get to change out his hat too
but what about the chest piece the leg
piece like give me very different bits
of gear like Kano really lends himself
to it I like the different eyepieces
with Kano the different mechanical
hearts with Kay now the different
outfits some of the sometimes he has
tattoos sometimes he doesn't sometimes
young sometimes it's older kaenel is one
of the most fun characters to change out
gear with some aren't
interesting his cane like you look at my
katana builds they all look identical
just different colors yeah there may be
a small difference she has this like
little half cape in the back maybe she
doesn't but generally her outfit is the
same set of pajamas you do have the
option of changing out special moves
like in injustice - you had to find the
special moves it's like they were they
were item drops or something this seems
to have all of them out there and you
can just build everyone how you want I
always feel like I [ __ ] that up if
you're like I'm gonna go on the internet
like are at best build for scorpion best
build for noob saibot best build for
Kano best build for sub-zero who are
never used because he's kind of clunky
so I feel like I could just have the
game makers decide for me what build is
best that's what they did with MK X and
it worked for me but I'm glad you don't
have to unlock moves it just makes it
better there's already enough [ __ ] to
grind and unlock in here it's I don't
need to do it for moves you do have to
find the brutalities though so there is
that I hate to live in a world where I
don't have all the alle days begin the
grind plus some of their intro dialogues
are a bit limited sometimes like you'll
have the revenant skin I feel like the
revenant skin should be revenant
dialogue but like yeah it's Jade like
what was it like fighting my revenant as
the revenant I'm like I don't know
you're the revenant you tell me what it
was like
it's weird dialogue for that skin I do
think the Crypt is great it's grindy as
hell so that's the thing that's not so
great about it but the Crypt itself is
like this weird third-person adventure
that's pretty fun the next Mortal Kombat
I fantasize of a world where it's not
just a crypt anymore it's like the world
I give me the Crypt mechanic from this
game but give me a world like in Mortal
Kombat deception where you go to
different realms and find different
chests you talk to people I'd be a lot
of fun just have this little RPG
elements in there and I like the layout
like really it's Shang zooms island is
the Crypt so you go to all the locations
from Mortal Kombat 1 that were staging
as the fighting stages the Mortal Kombat
one but it's laid out how his island
would be it makes it feel really alive I
really like what they did with the Crypt
here so in the end Mortal Kombat 11 it's
fun like I feel like after Mortal Kombat
I played Mortal Kombat acts I knew
exactly how to play Mortal Kombat acts
is an extension of 9 this there is a
learning curve I can speak to their
intent but it does feel like they've
structured Mortal Kombat 11 to appeal to
evil players and competitive players
more I feel like they want Mortal Kombat
11 to be like you know the staple of
competitive play now that people talked
a lot of
about the new Street Fighter game I
appreciate what they did with the meter
burn mechanic making you have to use
them as a main part of the gameplay that
kind of forced me to use it and I
realized what I've been missing by not
using it so much but I feel like
grinding for armor and the armor drops
the armored building building your
characters customizing your characters
and injustice - I felt like it was
better than Mortal Kombat 11 I feel like
the gameplay and Mortal Kombat acts just
speaks more to me personally than Mortal
Kombat 11 I'm having fun playing Mortal
Kombat 11 there are some neat changes
they did but not all of the changes
really gel with how I play Mortal Kombat
long story short Mortal Kombat 11 a lot
of fun worth buying at full price the
fatalities are pretty so it doesn't hurt
that the graphics are amazing it's like
every character has one fatality where
you're like alright yeah they died
that's the point of them and then they
have the other fatality where you're
like [ __ ] yes or some Mortal Kombat 11
have you played it what did you think
about it how does it compare to the
other Mortal Kombat games at least 9 X
and 11 what's the order best - worse
worse - best whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]